hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'm going to teach you how you can
calculate the day of the week that New
Year's happens until the year 2099 the
easiest way to do this is to use a
spreadsheet or to use a website like
Wolfram Alpha Wolfram Alpha is very easy
to use you simply type in the date and
it will tell you the day of the week so
2015 the new year starts on a Thursday
but how can we do this in our head let's
try and find a pattern in the day that
the new year starts in 2001 the new year
started on a Monday in 2002 it started
on a Tuesday in 2003 it started one day
ahead which is Wednesday in 2004 the new
year also started one day ahead on
Thursday so by this pattern you would
think that 2005 started on a Friday but
it in fact started on a Saturday and the
reason for this is that 2004 was a leap
year and that extra day in the leap year
pushed the new year to start one day
ahead so we have a general rule that
every year pushes the new year to start
one day ahead except a leap year it will
start two days ahead in the year 2000
which was also a leap year it would have
started two days before Monday which is
a Saturday and we can see the pattern
will continue as we continue the years
so we want to come up with a
mathematical formula to calculate the
day the new year starts a preliminary is
we're going to make numerical codes for
each of the days Sunday being a zero and
Saturday being a six
there's some mnemonics you can use to
remember this like Sunday as sans day
Monday is one day Tuesday is Tuesday
Wednesday is trebles day Thursday is
fours day Friday is five day and
Saturday is six a day so now let's try
and come up with the numerical formula
to come up with the day that the new
year starts given the year 2000 why why
so we know we want to start out with the
new year the day that it started in 2000
plus we're going to add one day for
every additional year beyond the year
2000 so that's 2000 YY minus 2000 we
also want to add in an extra day for the
number of leap years so we can simplify
this formula in 2000 we know the new
year started on a Saturday which is a 6
mm YY - mm we'll just be YY and the
number of leap years can be found by
dividing YY divided by 4 and rounding it
up because 2000 was also leaker so in
order to convert this into a day code we
want to take this modulo 7 in other
words we take the remainder upon
dividing by 7 because we want the number
to be between 0 and 6 so let's try out
this formula it looks complicated but it
actually be something that's very simple
and you can do it in your head so let's
do the new year let's see which day the
new year 2017 we'll start it we start
out with the 6 in the formula the 17 we
add to 6 and 17 divided by 4 rounded up
will be 5
so we add 617 and 5 to get 28 when we
divide this by 7 there's a remainder of
0 so the the day code will be 0 and that
means 2017 we'll start on a Sunday and
you can actually check this this is a
correct formula and it works so this is
not too hard but you saw the numbers
we're getting bigger so one adjustment
is will change the 6 into a negative 1
because 6 and negative 1 are the same
when you consider the remainder by 7
there's another trick we can do so let's
try the new year of 2070 1 we have a
negative 1 and then for 71 we put in
plus 71 so instead of keeping track of
big numbers and adding them we'll just
add these two right now in our head so
negative 1 plus 71 is 70 and we can in
fact just look at the remainder by 7
right now when we divide 70 by 7 we get
0 so that whole term vanishes the final
term is 71/4 rounded up which is 18 we
then consider the remainder of this from
7 which is 4 so that means 4 is our day
code and therefore 2071 will start on a
Thursday so this formula is something
that you can use it's actually a pretty
fun formula you can take any year from
2000 and 2099 and figure out when the
new year started and once you know this
trick you can actually extend it to find
the day of any date and if you're
interested I'll make a future video on
that I hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog bind
your decisions on Twitter at pressure
Walker and you can get my books listed
on my website